I really like what Dave says in this
lesson called Variables Can Vary, and
I want to keep a record of the code
that he writes in this video.
So I'm actually just going to write
it myself in my starter code file.
And after I copy the code,
I'm going to add some comments
that tell me what this code is
all about and why it's important.
I think I'll even include a link
to the video so I can go back and
reference it later.
In Python, you can add notes to a code
file by using the pound symbol.
Basically, that tells the computer
to ignore everything on that line
after the pound symbol, so this way
I can write stuff that is meant for
people to read instead of computers.
When I come to a quiz node I can
choose to switch to my browser and
answer the quiz in the Udacity classroom
or I can write my answer in my
starter code file and just copy and
paste it over when I'm ready to submit.
I think I'll do that.
That way I can keep a record of my
quiz code just for my own reference.
Awesome, I passed the quiz.
If I ever want to see
what any of my code does,
I can easily do that in Sublime.
All I have to do is go up to
the menu bar, click tools and
then go to build, or as a shortcut,
I can press Cmd+B on Mac or
Ctrl+B on Windows.
When I click build, a screen shows on
the bottom of my Sublime window and
it shows the output of my code.
Doing this often will really help me
get into the habit of running my code.
And it will help me a lot when I
start working on big projects.
All right, this is looking pretty good.
I'll save this file on my computer
in a place where I'll keep
all of my Intro to
Programming Nanodegree starter code.
Now you can easily open this file and
check it out again.
If I forget any of this content or
I just want a reference to
stuff that I've written before.